[Music]
into the windows of my mind
a somber Gathering that no family would
ever want
30 years from the racist murder of
Stephen Lawrence his loved ones were
joined by dignitaries to celebrate his
life and Legacy
he's quite a boy
he was a handsome boy a clever boy
a boy full of love
his whole life reflected that love
and among the reflections criticism 2 of
those who took 20 years to bring his
Killers to Justice
our progress may be made the Met remains
institutionally racist
rather we must confront this truth and
recommit
to eradicating racism from the Met and
from every every other sector and aspect
of our society
words that must have stung the Met
commissioner seated close to the
Lawrence Family for him Stephen's
brother Steward had this message there
are some people
in this room
that can make
a difference
and can make
a change
and change is what's a mark Rowley vowed
to make since getting the top job at the
Met a force that was condemned as
institutionally racist in the wake of a
bungled investigation into Stephen
Lawrence's death
but 30 years on it seems little has
changed last month a major review of The
Metropolitan Police found that it was
homophobic misogynistic and still
institutionally racist and while the Met
commissioner apologized and admitted
that the force had let black communities
down he refused to describe the racism
as institutional
some of those who worked in the Met have
implored the commissioner to go further
find some heart find some compassion
can you imagine how they must be feeling
when you as the leader of the
organization the Metropolitan Police
have refused to accept institutional
racism within your Force at the spot
where Stephen Lawrence died his father
paid his own private tribute
he sounds deaf now a bigger symbol of
race relations in Britain
Milena vist Sky News